new in theaters this weekend John wake
chapter three Parabellum a dog's journey
and the Sun is also a star what will you
see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
peanu in theaters this weekend John wick
chapter three Parabellum he's back
ladies and gentlemen and this third
installment of the JW franchise do you
expect you to meet the dollars fourteen
million dollar bounty on his head and
everyone in the city wants a piece of it
I say the other boat even after learning
that there is a 14 million dollar
contract on his life and being declared
excommunicate oh and that he's being
hunted by really good assassins for the
14 million duh j-dub must escape New
York City which should be easy there's
like 16 bridges or services still
off-limits what do you need
guns lots of guns this movie is for you
if you like the first two John wick
movies you find Keanu Reeves as an
action hero freakin awesome or you like
dogs I've lived a lot of lives there's a
lot of different dogs but I always found
my way back to Ethan
[Music]
that isn't getting any easier that is
getting it easier also at this weekend a
dog's journey this heartwarming
comedy-drama will have you wagging your
tail as the sequel to the 2017 uh dogs
purpose in this movie Bailey the dog
promises his boy Ethan that in his next
life he will find and protect Ethan's
granddaughter CJ begin uncontrollable
sobbing session now you just keep taking
care seat you get up for anything no
matter how many lives it took I would be
there for CJ oh hello where did you come
from like he chose you
this move is for you if you like the
first film a dog's purpose you're
looking to shed some water weight
through bawling your eyes out or you
like dogs it's okay no Fox calls wait
let me guess not all of them I don't
believe in love what if I told you I
could get you to fall in love with me
just give me a day an hour finally out
this weekend the Sun is also a star I
got that right right this pg-13 teen
drama follows the love story of quantum
physics student Natasha and her new
exchange student Bay Daniel Bay when
your key ingredients to fall in love my
ingredients are friendship chemistry The
X Factor what's the X Factor don't worry
we've got it
while falling in love the to struggle
with both young people problems and the
threat of deportation this new york city
romance is based on the young adult
novel by the same name
you think they'll run into John wick cuz
they're both in New York
[Music]
this movies for you if you love love
stories young adult novels turn young
adult movies is your jam or you like
dogs it's not really a dog movie but you
know comedy comes in threes that is your
weekend ticket what will you see
and check back next week for a whole new
world I like dogs
[Music]